extreme weather events will and in many
cases already have hit transport power
and water networks and not only in less
developed countries so are governments
preparing in the right way and have we
focused too much on mitigation are you
doing whatever we can to slow climate
change rather than adaptation dealing
with the effects of climate change now
and in the future uh so zyatong are we
doing enough on adaptation
i would say absolutely we're not yet
doing enough this hit home for me very
viscerally i'm from british columbia
where this summer of course a heat dome
killed 600 people and also killed a
billion marine animals and fried the
town of litton bc a mere six months
later our highways have been washed away
by an atmospheric river and now most of
our farmland is two meters under water
there are no adaptation standards in
place and in fact at cop 26 this year
about 79 countries put in adaptation
plans but here's the thing only 50
percent of those had implementation
strategies and so those were more like
risk assessments we can see that there
might be a problem coming but what we
really need is funding finance to build
and strategize and actually have
coherent plans for what we're going to
do to it to adapt finally the thing that
we need to address is trans boundary
adaptation plans we have to put our john
lennon hats on and realize that many of
the concerns we're going to face are
going to be regional and not just locked
within national boundaries as well and
and tom
it's an extraordinary figure here this
year climate disasters could cost the us
more than 100 billion dollars in damages
so there's a financial argument for
adaptation isn't there so what's your
take on it are we getting that balance
between mitigation adaptation right or
not
well i think we haven't i mean you
started this section off by saying have
we focused too much on mitigation you
can't focus too much on mitigation
because there is a point beyond which
we're not going to be able to adapt to
the changes but i think the point is
also true there that we also need to
focus on adaptation and that is an issue
of justice as much as anything else i
mean what we're seeing at the moment is
the most vulnerable countries already
experiencing the worst impacts of
climate change and when we come to
negotiations such as at cop26 they
repeatedly say to the world look unless
you are prepared to demonstrate global
solidarity with us in dealing with the
impact of this problem that after after
all we haven't caused then you know we
need to think about how we can create a
deal where we share the mitigation
efforts as well so i would say the two
are interlinked we can only make more
progress on mitigation reducing
emissions if we also demonstrate global
solidarity on adaptation on all of us
facing the impacts that are already
locked in together and zion do you think
that the richer countries are more
likely to be on board when they
experience the effects of climate change
themselves canada for example your home
country
well i think that there is definitely
growing awareness we are we have an
adaptation center here at the university
of waterloo colombia is doing incredible
research so it is just starting now but
of course as as you know tom was just
saying these effects are being felt in
the least developed countries right now
and hopefully we're going to see some
changes because next year at charmel
sheck it's going to play center focus uh
really the next cop 27 is going to be
focused on adaptation and resilience tom
do you think that's right and and do you
think that the countries will stump up
the cash for those suffering the most
well i mean i we the the big jump is yet
to be made right i mean there was some
evidence at cop26 that right now 80
billion of adapt of of climate finance
is flowing every year only 25 percent of
that is focused on adaptation and there
was a commitment to double that in the
next couple of years at cop26 now that
is progress and it's great that we're
giving the political airtime to this
issue but just recently the un
demonstrated that on the emissions
trajectory that we're on adaptation
could cost developing countries as much
as 300 billion a year by 2030 so
we need a new framework in which we
think about this where there is deeper
solidarity where we have the financing
mechanisms in place to properly support
regeneration of natural systems support
of infrastructure around the world
because without that we're going to see
really devastating impacts and it's
morally indefensible at a moment where
we have spent 19 trillion in just the
last year and a half to recover from the
covid pandemic through quantitative
easing and other solutions so as a
result of that we can't really say we
can't afford it we can afford it we need
to demonstrate the determination to do
so